Hallie is Alive and Well in the latest
trailer for The Little Mermaid and I am
shook I'm so proud of my little baby
she's not like my baby but you get it
she's come a long way since grown-ish
plus this trailer is truly breathtaking
and Disney heard all of our requests and
made flounder not as scary as this one
or this one so I'm very excited for this
live-action Little Mermaid I love The
Little Mermaid I still love The Little
Mermaid I'm a Disney girl I'm a Disney
adult whatever label you want to give me
who loves Disney Princesses and cannot
wait for this one my dream has always
been to be a Disney princess and in some
ways I am Tiana
[Music]